welcome back to Hannity so in light of
all that has happened in Houston and of
course Texas you know what their Trump
supporters really good people including
recording artists kya Jones and joy
Villa they've been on the ground in
Houston helping victims and raising
money a hurricane Harvey and tonight we
will find a word from them and that good
work they're doing here's tonight's
final word Texas is coming together no
matter the color the creed the religion
everyone is uniting it really showed us
how America should be uniting at this
time that's right and tonight we want to
tell you we need more efforts and more
help over there the hurricane Harvey
damage has been catastrophic but the
people's spirits are strong strong and
unity we saw all colors all creeds
coming together under one flag the
American flag so tonight we want to
remind you America we are Texas strong
and please do everything you can to
donate help and send your prayers to
Texas that's been tonight final word all
right in spite of all the devastation it
really does at times bring the goodness
and greatness out of the American people
we've seen that for the people our
friends our neighbors in Texas